Another day, another tidy explanation of what
seems to be a gaping plot hole in Avengers:
Endgame.
As ever, major spoilers ahead.
The flick's directors, Joe and Anthony Russo,
addressed a bunch of burning questions during
a recent Q&A in China.
Among these: why couldn't Doctor Strange simply,
say, portal Thanos' Infinity Gauntlet hand
into another dimension?
Now, this is an excellent question for one
simple reason: those yellow sparklies have
proven to be quite effective as a weapon.
In Avengers: Infinity War, during Wong's battle
with Cull Obsidian, the gigantic beast had
his arm severed by one of the portals.
Why couldn't Doctor Strange have done the
exact same thing to Thanos during Endgame's
climactic clash?
Here's the Russos' response, according to
We Got This Covered:
"Thanos' skin is almost impenetrable, we don't
know whether Doctor Strange had the capability
to do it.
If he failed to cut it on time, Thanos would
still be able to do the snap.
Doctor Strange realized this issue during
his millions of test runs."
That last part actually seems like an extremely
strong explanation.
You could rely on that as an answer to just
about any variation of the same question,
and it kind of defies second-guessing.
Strange didn't attempt to lay the old magical
arm-chopping trick on Thanos because he knew
it wouldn't work.
In fact, he had already seen every possible
strategy for defeating the Mad Titan, 14,000,605
of them, to be exact, during his future viewing-fest
on Titan in Infinity War.
And he alone was privy to the one strategy
out of all of those that would work.
In order for Thanos to ultimately fail, he
would first have to succeed.
Strange would have known that there was no
way to stop him from gathering all of the
Infinity Stones, and no way to prevent the
Decimation from happening.
Hence his one condition for voluntarily offering
up the Time Stone to Thanos: that Tony Stark's
life be spared.
Without Stark around to perfect the technology
for time travel, the Avengers' strategy of
deploying teams to various points in time
to pre-emptively acquire all of the stones
wouldn't have been possible.
Strange knew, as well, that only Stark, who
designed the Infinity Gauntlet 2.0, would
have the wherewithal to pull the ol' Gauntlet
switcheroo on Thanos at the crucial moment.
That's the beauty of the Russos' explanation:
it's basically bulletproof, and it applies
to literally any alternate scenario.
Why didn't our heroes attempt the same trick
they had on Titan, using Mantis to distract
Thanos until someone could yank his Gauntlet
off?
Well, because Strange knew it wouldn't work.
Why didn't Stark use his nearly all-powerful
nanotech to build a Thanos-sized suit of armor
that would trap the Mad Titan and fly him
into the sun?
Because Strange knew it wouldn't work.
Why didn't Captain Marvel just crater his
big purple butt?
Ask Doctor Strange.
He'll tell you it's because he knew it wouldn't
work.
The more you think about Strange's viewing
of those millions of possible outcomes, the
more mind-blowing it becomes as a storytelling
device, or a convenient little storytelling
cheat, depending on your point of view.
On the surface, the line seems to illustrate
for the audience just how stacked the odds
were against our heroes.
But more than that, it also allows Marvel
to dismiss any and all questions beginning
with "Why couldn't they have just" in one
fell swoop.
At any rate, the Russos have been busy shutting
down all the "full of plot holes" talk since
Endgame's release, and their explanations
should only motivate you to take in repeat
viewings at your earliest convenience to see
if they check out.
Armed with their insider knowledge, you'll
probably want to go check it out another time
or two while it's still in theaters.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one!